كنحاول انقل يعني المعاناه ديال منطقه باب
برد عبر مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
وكنتوصل يعني من طرف الساكنه المحليه ديال
البوادي والقرى ديال الاقليم شفشاون باي
خبر جديد يتعلق باي حادثه
من بين هذا الاخبار اللي كانت توصل بها هو
خبر سقوط الطفل ريان في ثقب مائي بدوار
اغراض جماعه
وقمت يعني بنشر الخبر
يعني سويعات بعد سقوط الطفل في البئر ثم
يعني انتشر الخبر عبر مختلف المواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي الاخرى
كان ابن المنطقه منطقه باب برد الاب ديال
ريان والعائله ديال اصدقاء احنا كابناء
المنطقه
درسنا يعني درسنا مع بعضنا يعني ان نلتقي
يوميا يعني في السوق الاسبوعي في المقاهي
هاد الناس
كواحد من افراد العائله لاننا كما قلنا
احنا ابنائها منطقه واحده
من تدوينه صفحه باب برد التي يتابعها
حوالي تسعه الاف مستخدم على فيسبوك تحولت
القضيه الى وسن انقذوا ريان الذي سجل
تغريده على موقع التدوينات القصيره تويتر
ليصبح الاعلى تداولا في المغرب والعالم
العربي
تفاجا بانتشار الخبر اولا على المستوى
الوطني حيث يعني تناقلت مختلف الجرائد
والقنوات العموميه المغربيه في اليوم يعني
في نفس اليوم انتقل الخبر الى يعني
اخبار عالميه